i'd like to uh just
give you some appreciation for the fact
that you've brought a bong
a hundred percent of the times you've
come on the show
yeah i don't go nowhere without my bong
i promise you nowhere like i like that
because it you know when i was a little
kid my dad would only smoke out of a
bong
and i was like little and i always
thought it was called a bomb a bomb
and um i remember like telling my
friends at school when i was like in
kindergarten or first grade like yeah my
daddy smokes out of a bomb
and uh
some someone told the teacher that [ __ ]
uh
and then my my they they pull my my
parents into the uh principal's office
and uh
yeah it was over a bong
but yeah what what are you like
never on the backwoods never on the like
are you strictly a bong hitter what does
i'm gonna say to get down
so
what i do is i roll a swisher up okay i
wrote a swisher up and i take pizza i'm
switching and just put it in my bones
you got the leaf there yeah that's nice
weed in there oh there's a weed in there
okay
but yeah i just roll the swisher up take
pizzas off and
put it in my bone i don't know like you
know
yeah like rose's type so will you put a
roach in the yeah i just break a piece
off my blood and put it in there type
[ __ ] wow i was in uh
alabama
like tuskegee type [ __ ] out there like
[ __ ] around i was broke as a
[ __ ] trying to save money and we
i started smoking chocolate swishers out
there right
then i started running out of like money
to buy [ __ ] bro so i used to smoke
roaches out of a bomb
and got so accustomed to smoking roaches
out of a bomb
now i'm
that's your all this money and i still
do the same [ __ ] yeah
you ever like going to a studio session
and the ashtrays got a bunch of roaches
no i don't touch nobody else roaches i
don't touch nobody else you never know
nah
like i said i wrote me up a bun not
break it down and put it